is looking the other way  art back outside again  Kuzma it's another three the lakers  defensive  got a switch now trying to get it down  to Tuesday's big potty good pitch up by  Houston these pours anyway capella  doesn't have to think about there's a  long lens of Ole Miss rebound goes back  to Koosman who hits a three  well Trevor already in double figures  which means double figures now in eight  straight games for the former Lakers  Kasbah scorching right now whose but  tonight is 5 for 5 from the field  just a few moments ago so they're trying  to get it laced within ten  there's Kuzma against  rockets  the way back beforehand Kuzma what  22 inside touka ready to shoot because  that's what the Lakers are giving up  theirs to play great defense on Harden  and Paul kuzmic puts it up for two  Rockets gotta hustle now get over and  cover these guys Kuzma  Ingram in a hurry  sets up whose model for an easy two and  the Rockets have to call it that round